sometimes watching a movie just won't do
you also want to eat that movie and
that's why there's movie recipes today
we're going to show you how to make
Braveheart freedom fries that is a batch
of freedom fries that tastes exactly
like the movie Braveheart
before you begin take off your pants and
underwear and put on a kilt if you don't
have a kilt just take off your pants in
underwear
hand cut your potatoes with a sword if
you don't have a sword handy you can
improvise but your freedom fries will
taste less violent line your pan with
aluminum foil and then cover it with
green sugar topping to simulate a grassy
battlefield place one half of the chips
on one side of the pan and one half of
the chips on the other side of the pan
leaving a large field of aluminum foil
and green in between both sets of chips
make sure you designate one side as
English chips in one side of Scottish
chips place eleven tater tots in the
center like so apply blue dye on the top
top now get a bottle of Johnnie Walker
red and pour it all over the Scottish
side don't worry that Johnnie Walker
didn't exist until the 1800s historical
accuracy is not a concern now pour an
entire bottle of evil or vinegar on the
English side be sure to let that
marinate for about three hours
cook the chips and tocks in an oven at
20 degrees for 15 minutes now stir the
chips and tots around and apply liberal
amounts of ketchup everywhere you can
except for the tots of course once the
stirring is done through all your chips
with ketchup onto the cold hard ground
where those stay remain outside use a
toothpick to dig out all the insides of
the tops applying liberal amounts of
ketchup now cut the blue taut from the
rest of the other tots with an axe
screaming freedom to add flavour take
all the remains and put them in the four
corners of your yard to make a point for
other potatoes in the area eat nothing
mmm oscar-worthy
[Music]